2022 لم يكن عاما الانعاش الاقتصادي
فبينما لا يزال اقتصاد العالم يتعافى من
تبعات جائعات كورونا حيث تلقى انتكاسات
موجعه دفعت الى الهبوط ورسمت صوره قاتمه
لما هو قادم فقبل نحو شهر لقى صندوق النقد
الدولي ناقوس الخطر مرجحا ان تتفاقم
الازمه الاقتصاديه في ظل الاستمرار التضخم
المرتفع والخلل في الامدادات وانعدام
الامن الغذائي الناجمي عن حرب اوكرانيا
وخفض الصندوق توقعاته للنمو العالمي لعام
2023-2.9 الى
2.7 بالمئه هذه توقعات عزيزها تقرير او
صدر اليوم عن مركز ابحاث الاقتصاد
والاعمال في لندن
ان يواجهها الاقتصاد العالمي خطر الركود
في العام المقبل التقرير السنوي للمركز
رسم صوره قاتمه الاقتصاد العالم في ظل
المعركه التي يخوضها صناعه السياسه خصوصا
ضد ارتفاع الاسعار في هذه المعركه ضد
التضخم لم تنتصر بعد ببساطه لانها تكلفه
خفض التضخم الى مستويات مقبوله تعني نمو
اضعف متوقعا لعدد من السنوات القادمه كل
هذه توقعات المتشائمه مشاهدينا تعني اننا
امام عام صعب سيؤثر بشكل مباشر على جيوب
المواطنين وحياتهم اليوم
[موسيقى]